для про європейських політики в марин ле
пін
починаєш осетію для правих популістів
крутила не з них одягнути новий rich
не прес-конференції он вона чула шум
не бачу тата листка хочеш бути чоппер
муфти на президентських виборах на 8
осередків
of удар моя кандидатура моя глибину
обожнювання і на викреслю вирішу частину -
розпочинаємо організовану кампанію проти
алсу компанію я казанову по вірна
порядок у Франції поглибити халед force
програма правих популістів
видного вигляду євро ви хитрий а також
роботи францію знову сильну vpn моя
приклад для успадкування дональд трамп
до mixed овочу ви рублів ківок ford
вид мало все вид плані у вата
фабрику макс йти на кора sti вирубні
tv shop чи челсі навіть не
рут акціонізм створе nuvi робочі місця
стор грн кількість вас знаходять пит ринку у
багатих французі погляду на відривали
економічніше на Україні і в будинках
є вигляд традиційних політичних парку
при вологи чинний президент олланд ери
кордони популярні такого низького
рейтингу не було зручно біля у
папороті
land не болоту в автоматі на другому
Однак термін своєї зупинки варич не
промо vip резиденцію тебе лист на рік у
брати і насти віку франція моїх ти де
прищу гарантія гвинт це для почету на
європейське кіно про не брати і росте вам
як можна у єври тієї ще наш околиця
зберегти це за стінами чого не буде
під датою зовсім внутрішній ринок
шивана хоче повернути і національну
валюту
ще залишиться якші дітей до screamin'
уват йому для них і не державу цієї
Франція
лише дивом але лапин повернулася пекла і
наземні банки в засіки російських
рахунку фінансування своєї передвиборчої
кампанії по устілці всі фінансові інститути
франції відро води та у тему
а за його слова ливани ще до законності
про Една не криму до Росії на підставі
не викликаного референдуму та сбу України
розряду і можна весь голос тощо.
персоною нон грата
ну судячи чиї вуста їх досвіду а не промок
тіла піну франції малюків candida твіт
консерваторію франсуа фійон для брюсселя
гвинт баштової кандидатки все правда у за
зовнішньої політики фійон е к л м н
виступає за новою не одяг про вік
і цивіка видно чоловіка за тими ти за собою
зради досвіду нею санкцій проти Росії
обидві заміни у нормандському форматі
[музика]